tumblr and whatever people would post
and so me and my friends all were in
broken homes and whatnot and so we would
we would talk about cutting and burning
the flag lighters and stuff it was
almost like a competition like oh yeah
well my life sucks so I did this and I
wrote fat on my on my thigh and oh yeah
well my dad yelled at me yesterday you
know I'm saying like I was like Brian
letting you do whatever you sort of
wanna did he have like no there are no
guidelines no discipline like be home by
10:00 did you have to be home at 10:00
our life was kind of crazy like there
were we would travel and stuff and I I
would be on the road with him when he
went sorry let me backtrack when he left
corn he started a solo project
Brian had Walsh ban and then later was
love and death and they would play shows
at bars and little clubs and stuff and I
would I would go on the road and be
doing homework at like 3 a.m. so my life
was a little different in that way I
would say like he tried to be strict and
be like the dad and whatever but our
life was too inconsistent that it didn't
it wasn't there she didn't have it
wasn't like we lived in a town and her
friends were in town and she could go
and then hang out till 10 it was like
hey we're going on the road this month
next month
dad I want to go to Phoenix and visit my
friends cuz we just live in Phoenix and
so I'd flyer out there and talk to the
parents so they're gonna be good and
then you know and then she got into some
stuff that way but when did she start
lashing out
when was it like you know the whole I
hate you I'm tired of you when did you
know like you got to step up how do you
sit there and say hey you need help when
you're the one who needed help for so
long and how does that give you any kind
of validity right was she always
questioning that she was questioning a
lot what do you think thirteen and a
half or something yeah I would say um
when I hit 7th grade I really started to
hurt you know I really started to
experience the pain of things but yeah I
started to I think voice a and lash out
and really self-harm when I was 13 and
were you devastated by this yeah totally
because I you know I tried to discipline
her but like I'd say give me your phone
you're not gonna have it for a couple
days and then she'd say okay I'm doing
my homework now I'm doing it and then
she would do it and say come on I did it
I'm not gonna do it no more and she
would say please you know like Bart
Simpson keeps repeating him
yeah okay you don't remember that well I
would never hold the discipline yeah I
was a good manipulator yeah and this is
hard because at a time you felt like you
you've got a left at all
you want to raise your daughter you're
having this relationship well I guess
this is at this point when did you leave
the ban in 2005 2005 and you kind of
rejoin like that [ __ ] started you
started touring with them a little later
right
yeah like eight years later when she was
14 almost 15 so it was a long time I
know it's kind of it's crazy story right
it's it is crazy it's hard to keep up
with the timeline yeah and it's just
like you know you have it's especially
like when you you found yourself and you
found God and all these things and then
you have a daughter that's acting out
and then she's you know she wants
attention and she's suffering and she's
hurting and it's like again how do you
not fall back into that you know like I
kind of did this for you in a way but
you understand fully what she's doing
and why she's doing it and these were
her feelings and she's had these deep so
it's very I mean it probably takes a lot
of therapy where you guys going to
therapy together we we tried therapy
yeah she wasn't really having it and
well I feel like kids in sorry
I mean cutting you off I feel like kids
who have attachment issues therapy
doesn't work because bonding is scary
and and the only reason the only reason
you would you would tell your feelings
to someone or the only reason they would
want to know is because they want
something from you it's not just because
they care about you and so therapy
scared me and why would I tell this
woman that I don't even know all these
things that happen to me and and what if
she what if she snitches on me you know
what if I tell her something and then I
get in trouble you know and so it just
it just didn't work and did you feel
like you were absolutely a hundred
percent honest with her yeah no I mean I
tried to be but you know what I did I
carried around so much that that
self-hatred I had when I was growing up
it was and then I couldn't get together
had so much rage and anger problems and
I remember she said one day she was like
I said I'm sorry you know cuz I blew up
and she's like you're not sorry if
you're sorry you wouldn't keep doing it
but that's you don't
Stan I can't stop doing I can't control
myself my anger sometimes you know how
bad I want to I want to but she couldn't
comprehend it at 40 she's probably
thinking well if you can't control
yourself and if you can't why are you
telling me to control myself
yeah like she didn't respect when I
would say okay you're gonna do this or
did it as a parent it's like she didn't
respect that because I was such a mess
you know it was like we're brother older
brother and sister something right and
she just wanted a dad in a way right I
mean in a lot of ways and I'm just all I
had was the the massive love for her
everything else discipline and and I
just didn't have I didn't have sorry no
I could see you're getting emotional now
while you're getting up doctor talk to
me about that
sorry no I think it's important well I
think from the from the start just you
you don't really when you go through
trauma like that like being being left
alone with skinheads and your mom
abandoned to you and leaves you as a 16
year old and her boyfriend at 4 days and
your dad comes home and you you know you
have from about the house to house it
takes years and layers to like really
heal from that